[Music]
welcome back to the djinns million
podcast or I guess this week it's Jenna
head and Jill Jenna head and arms and
neck assured okay to where I don't think
there's any fixing that I think I think
you've gotten what you wanted everybody
you get a floating in Jenna head for
this podcast I didn't actually think
about it when they put the shirt on foot
now that it's here I'm gonna keep it on
sometimes all wear green or your well
green and we'll be able to like color
correct it so we're it turns into like a
blue but that is exactly the same color
as the green screen so the chances are
there's no Jenna torso today
I'm fine with it honestly just make the
whole thing disappear
Wow
it's incredible almost as incredible as
post mates if you guys haven't heard
post mates is a great delivery app to
deliver you all the food that you love
that you may not want to go pick up
yourself for any number of reasons go to
the App Store download post mates use
code Jenna and Julian for $100 off
delivery for your first 7 days of using
the app or click the link down below
also farmers dog specially formulated
farm-to-table meals for your pets they
will love it our dogs love it
Kerma is nasty and he fuels his nasty
spirit with farmers dogs so go too far
the farmers dog dog sausage and Angelina
get 50% off your first two weeks or
click the link down in the description
below
gracias sponsors Heisei sponsors in
spanish hey Siri how do you say sponsors
in Spanish patrocinadores fat Josie
Natori
gracias patrocinadores for to support
Eden arrow see
thank you for the dinero in the support
and giving us good deals on things
patro seen near darkness we can all day
YouTube no no tienen mad does what is
here now
Channel good how do you spell that so to
Spanish she cannot all day YouTube note
the anymore that is let's go for a swim
down the canal of YouTube blabla meat I
know vomiting weight is a vomit our
vomit no yeah see my friend I play elder
scrolls with teaches me Spanish learning
Spanish when you play oh yeah well you
need friend man
cuz I'm always like tell me how to say
this and then he tells me he tells it
cuz he's floor well yeah for the most
yeah he says he's not but he is pretty
much and then I said tell me how to say
my my youtube channel has no views me
canal de youtube no TN emeritus Wow
that is right minute I know I can fact
check that from my years of Spanish
speaking Playa Bonita
tango and vestido oh that's a dress I
always thought it was best but it's
dress Oh have no fear your soy vestido
Oh God who guys baseball
well baseball the end that's it thank
you for watching bye guys let me just
take a sip out of my Hydra flask that
was disgusting why are you doing that
I'm just go girl
um I've been called the disco girl by
you but not only you twitch chat has
been calling you visco girl for many
weeks now well look at your aesthetic
listen okay I don't understand why I'm
being called a visco girl I just don't
get it seems like unwarranted and I
don't think I deserve the title what did
you pull a small hydro flask out of your
fanny pack after drinking out of your
full sights hydro flask I'm not a disco
girl okay
I don't know what it means but I'm not
one and if I am one than I am one I am
what I am is that the Cat in the Hat
dr. Seuss I am what I am am I allowed to
just like leave after that yeah I mean
if I just I'll just pop the hydro flask
over in front of the market appear in
shirt I really can't wait to see what
that looks like they've been asking for
it they're always like please wear a
full head-to-toe green screen except for
your heads it's either that or tie your
mush that moustache and beard and hair
greener and then your eyes are floating
it never looks like that it never looks
like that it always looks like weird and
like fuzzy and it's like staticky
looking at it's like we don't even have
this we don't know how this thing lit
not really we need to have like lights
above the green screen that's kind of
why it doesn't look as good as it can
but even on a professional green screen
set what do you want just like a
cheekbone and an eye talking to you
well even in my MOOC bang but it's just
my mouth video like that took a lot of
finessing yeah it was still not you
could tell yeah that that was like a lot
of work we sat there for hours trying to
set that up and make that look good and
it's hard even if if you dyed your hair
green it wouldn't look like what you
guys want it to look like yeah it's it's
a combination of like perfectly like a
green screen and also like
post-processing yeah so I don't know how
this is gonna look at might look
terrible might look cool might like
nothing awesome it's gonna look awesome
but even like all these shadows like
from boobs like that will give it a good
though doesn't you know how's that knee
dude for clothing Jenna or lack of
clothing her for this podcast actually
because green equals no clothes thanks
for your thoughts disco girl
thoughts from this go girl I'm a disco
girl but I'm also a cam boy okay what
how are you a cam boy oh my cam boy I'm
I stream live on camera and I'm a boy I
don't think that makes you a cam boy huh
well then am i cam girl yeah okay all
right fine I'm a cam girl let's go you
just woke up buddy yeah she's the
daughter of a cam boy and a cam girl
it's a wild life she's living I'm going
to Big Bear with her that's quite a big
river that's again it's Bunny's first
time in Big Bear we're very excited
we are meeting our friend Brett and his
dog buzz up there so it's gonna be five
dogs and three humans and it's to
celebrate Jenna's birthday because their
birthdays in a week and how exciting 33
year old lady I'm excited we haven't
been up there was it since your last
birthday no we had been up there since
then we've gone up once we've gone up
twice the last year yeah but a massive
decrease in how much we used to go yeah
miss Big Bear you do I just want to take
food on a hike I know so I think
honestly she'll be like a little bit
like what the hell is going on at first
but it's gonna really love it I'm just
service for the car ride I mean you seem
to have this like thing in your brain
about how the car is gonna work but I'm
still like very confused because she
takes up the entire trunk and I have to
sit in the backseat so a lot of you guys
I've seen in any of our videos we have
like a raised um it's like a little dog
couch but it's a car seat for them and
oh yeah three little ones the seatbelt
goes through the back of it and then
their harnesses are attached to the
seatbelt so it actually does like you
know keep them safe as safe as I guess
we can in the car and um I that takes up
two seats it takes up the middle seat
and one of the back passenger seats and
then I sit in that little other third
seat which is pretty crammed at that
point cause a huge talk about next year
and the reason I sit there with bunny is
because she does this thing sometimes
where she puts her head over and she
gets excited and she will jump into
their car seat while they're in it she
thinks she's a small dog when it comes
to the car because she you drove her one
time and she jumped over the back seat
and sat in that cars yeah I think I took
a picture yeah yeah she like she liked
thing about greyhounds is like an even
little Italian grounds they like curl up
into like 1/4 their size they can really
like minimize and so I think it bunny
has this thing where she needs people or
dogs she needs to be with someone so if
she's ever isolated you know not on her
own accord like throughout the day
she'll go into the game room and isolate
herself but that's because she wants to
and she knows it's safe but in the
our she feels like sometimes where are
we going I want to be with you guys and
so she'll just get like a little overly
excited and then hop her 65-pound body
on to the dog bed whether the dogs are
there or not and so Jen is sort of there
as like the gatekeeper like no you can't
do that because I've tried from the
front seat and I can't it doesn't work I
always have to take off my seat belt and
go back there like somebody's angry
mother don't make me come back yeah and
starting at 8:30 in the morning to about
7:30 at night it's at least 85 to 90
degrees out where we live and it's
virtually impossible to walk them during
those hours because the pavements too
hot and it's too hot out like wet it's
just gonna be bad for them and so all
the greyhounds are pretty prone to
overheating
yeah there are they all run Bobby has a
fur coat on we just have a very
dysfunctional situation right now when
it comes to the dogs and traveling but
you say I have this like view of how
it's gonna go I think it's gonna go good
because I want it to go good I don't
have it I don't have a fear of her I
feel confident that she can make the the
two-hour drive or whatever I'm a little
nervous to how she's gonna do on like a
windy road but I'm nervous about how
we're packing the car because she takes
up the entire trunk she takes up the
whole truck and then I'm sitting in the
back seat that's already taken up by a
giant dog car seat which leaves us only
the front passenger seat to pack things
here's how I envisioned it okay tell me
your vision so her crate her her metal
crate folds up into this like rectangle
that's one dimensional it's like one
flat thing so right the other eye word
one dimensional absolutely not
well it's it's flat it's it's this thin
when you fold it up so it's just this
long rectangle so I think we put that in
the back seat lean it up against the dog
bed and then we throw literally
everything that we're bringing up there
food clothes drinks coolers all in the
front seat and then the end and then
bunny is just taking up the whole trunk
okay and see how it goes yeah well I
mean we're lucky that we don't ever
really bring we bring food and subsidy
don't have to go to the grocery store
when we get there but Julian and I just
share like a little bag because
yeah we don't when you're going on like
a nice little weekend we're just gonna
chill mm-hmm I end up just wearing like
the same thing one pair of clothes yeah
me too I mean I'm I learned that list
I'm probably not gonna change to be
honest I'm probably gonna drive up there
in this and then bring like a hoodie and
then that's that yeah so but regardless
we're gonna make it up and I'm excited
to go up there I think it's a very
necessary trip I mean it's your birthday
and we're celebrating but I think it's
good timing I think we're about to go to
twitchcon in a few weeks it's about to
get crazy a lot of stuff's going on and
it's just nice to get away for a little
staycation in the mountains yeah cuz I'm
gonna be 33 and you know every year my
birthday I like to do is nothing is
possible well here we go stars and drink
a glass of wine and think some thoughts
you know I love looking at the stars and
drinking alcohol I like both of those
things by themselves but when you put
them together it's it's a nice cocktail
of a good time yeah but then on my
actual birthday I won't play Elder
Scrolls online we'll see about that
why cuz I have to plan something very
birthday know every year we save
surprise party masses
I'm like Julian I want to do nothing and
he's like okay let's go out to dinner
and I'm like no thing no dinner got it
no no dinner reservation no don't want
to get dressed
dress up no thank you we're meeting a
group of our friends
no thank you we'll see I like to do
nothing for my birthday you like to do
like a little more for your birthday
well I have never been a big celebrate
err I mean I obviously like anyone you
know when you're young birthday parties
are fun but like as an adult I've never
been a huge celebrator of my birthday
with other people it's always been like
either just with you was that a party
for you like no but what I'm saying is
up until my 20 year no no my 25th
birthday okay I've been told my 25th
birthday I had never done that and then
you through this really rad party for me
we were rented out part of this bar and
we had all of my friends come and I
don't remember leaving mm-hmm I got your
shoes nah that was a really fun night
and then the next year or this last year
we had all of our friends fly in it was
like really fun because like
I don't know when we go to Lake
twitchcon and stuff our favorite part is
hanging on that friend so I was like
let's just extract that part of the
convention and just do it for my
birthday and it was really dope yeah so
I enjoy that but you on the other hand
are like don't look at me don't touch me
I'm eating my food and play elderscrolls
happy birthday to me yes I mean I can
touch you yeah I want to be left alone I
don't want to talk to anybody you like I
just want to like live yeah you got to
do you girl I'm pretty sure I did that
for my 28th and 29th birthday too as
well I said I just want to order fed you
girl yeah hell yeah dude all celebrate
y'all I'm gonna go out hit the town okay
while you're doing that and I'm gonna
just [ __ ] bottle service by myself for
your birthday I'm gonna be fist pumping
all the way to 33 year old lady style
without her no that's not my style I'm
gonna just be playing other video games
or watching something on TV I think I'll
check I'm excited cuz that means that I
definitely can play elder scrolls no
it's the Sunday Sunday sorry it isn't
sunny I thought yeah well Sunday's good
it's early
sometimes sometimes until it's nighttime
you're [ __ ] Mondays tomorrow oh I hate
that feeling about it I'm sorry I'm
sorry sorry well anyway we're going up
to mountains by the time you're watching
this we're gonna have been up and back
mm-hmm and it's just it's it's gonna be
good dogs really like it I tell you I am
a little concerned because at night we
hear coyotes sometimes a lot or even
during the day like if they're just
traveling in a pack yeah and it sounds
like a group of women screaming at the
top of their lungs like it's it's it's
woken me up in the middle of the night
mm-hmm
what's bunny gonna do and she hears that
she's gonna perk up her years like the
Regal little girl she is
and well we're gonna stay at a place
that has a fenced-in yard so that's good
so at night it's not gonna be the
biggest task in the world to take them
out but but she does have to go down and
up a flight of stairs in order to go
yeah the thing is like bunnies the stair
thing for her it was never just a one it
was never just like a physical thing it
was a physical thing at first but then
she learned the physical mechanics of
walking up stairs and then it became
like mental yeah do I do I really want
to go up these stairs I like nervous to
go up the stairs that guy want his thing
I want to stay down here
she's been tantruming at me at night
because she wants to sleep in the game
room and it was like you can't live your
whole life in the game room yeah as I
should be taking that advice to myself
pot calling the kettle black
now is she like my daughter yeah she is
she takes after her mom she doesn't want
to leave that room she really like she
really wants to stay in there like all
the time she doesn't want to go to bed
what is that noise that a truck it's a
truck it's really loud does it it might
be my hydrofloss you know what but yeah
I think I think once will set her up
like we're bringing her cray we'll set
her up her little home base in the
bedroom and show her that everything is
good and it might be a little tough at
first since we're gonna be arriving at
night but we'll figure it out I feel
like she'll probably do better with
those stairs cuz there's carpet on those
stairs that's true we don't have carpet
I'm excited to see bunnies first time
going up a set of carpeted stairs if
it's easier or harder for her I imagine
will be a lot easier it'll be a much
harder experience if she pees on those
carpets oh my god I do even a pool she
pees like an actual pool it's a lot of
pee it's a lot of pee then we have
hardwood floors almost everywhere so
that was calculated by the way it's not
an accident that we apply wood floors oh
my god you remember when we were little
any time that we've looked for a place
to live it's like if it has carpet
somewhere where you could close the door
like then it's okay because then you can
close the door and keep it closed but if
there's just like carpet I'm like I
think we can't do it man cuz when I
lived in Santa Monica I had carpets in
the bedrooms and it was just
I have little boy dogs that decide that
they don't care where the bathroom is
they're gonna go yeah and then I have
little girl dogs that she has poop shame
peach has poop shame and Bonnie shame
bunny
what she does is so late at night when I
want to let them out she does this thing
where she'll go outside do a little
circle and here's something that she
doesn't like she'll just sprint her ass
back in and then it'll be she'll be like
no I don't have to go and I'd be like
bunny I know you have to go and then all
right put the headphones back on she
creeps into the dining room forever
and so that that's something you know
I'm noticing that she runs once you
sprints in I'm like stop sign you have
to turn around and try again go back and
try gopi nothing's gonna get you but
every single day even still to this day
every single day she's getting a little
more calm and there's no snow in big
berry now but I'm interested to see her
see snow for the first time yeah there's
no snow it might actually be the coldest
she's ever been
Jagat baby yeah kid sounded like I think
my mom said it gets down to like 40 at
night right now oh my god is that real
his whole tongue is out of his mouth do
it but yeah we should bring her jacket
her adoption agency there's a woman that
knits them for greyhounds yeah she makes
it so sweet it's really great all right
crime I'm gonna take a pic show you but
what do you think he's thinking about
right now
look at this selfie beautiful that's on
and it's in front of a green screen
people can put that in whatever they
want that's perfect
subscribe to Jenna on Instagram for her
Instagram stories yeah subscribe
subscribe to Graham I wonder what he's
thinking about it's probably farmers dog
where'd you just pull that from he's
probably thinking about farmers dog
guys farmers loggers farm to farm to
table food for your dog that is
high-quality board certified that
veterinary approved ingredients okay we
have picky eaters okay marbles he's
about as picky as they get remember
Jenny used to have to sit with him while
he ate well to this day he Sprint's at
approximately a hundred miles an hour to
the kitchen when it's time to eat
because he knows farmers waiting for so
fast he's very fast faster than you
probably could imagine him ever running
and it's because farmers dog they have a
little questionnaire you fill out when
you sign up for your dog what are their
eating habits whether they like when do
they eat how much do they eat how big
are they what kind of dog everything
that you can think of and they take that
information and they formulate a meal
plan and they send you these pouches of
human grade high quality dog food for
your pets and it's a really great system
because you don't have to go anywhere it
ships right to your front door they they
bring dry ice to keep it frozen and
fresh go to the farmer's dog calm /gen
and julian i get 50% over the first two
weeks of the farmer's dog and I think
you're really know I get I don't even
need these papers I just did it as a
joke
also guys post mates is the delivery app
that everyone needs and if you haven't
tried it you're missing out post mates
will deliver something from the local
grocery store your favorite restaurant
around the corner wherever it is post
mates is there for you 24 hours a day
seven days a week
you just select what restaurant you want
you order it off the menu and then a
wonderful postman goes and picks it up
and hands it to you at your front door
and you say thanks and then they're like
alright no problem and then you're
eating and you didn't have to get out of
your socks and underwear a little YUM
it's young it's very young he's code
generally to get $100 off free delivery
credits here first 7 days of using the
app check it out you'd be surprised at
the amount of stuff that you can just
like postmates that you wouldn't have to
run to the store for because who wants
to sit in traffic who wants to put pants
on I don't want to put pants on do you
want to put pants on no never no I never
want to put pants on if I can go morning
tonight without having putted pants on
the entire time it's like a successful
day that's what I'm doing for my
birthday yeah no pants no pants no
worries no pants no shoes no problem
welcome to post space that's not their
slogan anyway we do have a little game I
wanted to play Thank You sponsors I want
I need him to play his tongue back in
his mouth dose I don't want it to get
dried out do this it's gonna pry it open
it's gonna get dry if you leave it out
it's really delightful what else please
don't pull out anything
okay that's appropriate you're allowed
to have a pen in there but I'm not sure
about that I'm not sure about that one
what's in there disco juice okay anyway
something that you guys have been asking
for for a lot of weeks now in the
comments is for me to go this doesn't
need to be here
marbles isn't here for me to go through
Jenna's old videos not all the videos
but the library of your videos I
actually didn't go tool because I tried
and it got weird and I was like I don't
think you're gonna like this yeah go
through your video she ate that and take
random lines that you've said and read
them to you to see if you can guess
which video that the line has been from
so I feel like this is either gonna be
really easy for me or really difficult
because I made some of them harder than
others like some of them are very
obscure that you can't get it's a good
luck thanks but then some of them are
like you should be able to get that well
yeah I feel like it could be either
really easy for me or really difficult
because every all of these videos
whatever it is you pulled them from I
made them all in one day
so and you kind of blacked out the whole
time well yeah I mean if you asked it's
like asking someone what they did on one
day four years ago and you're like I
don't know man it's documented I could
check but I don't [ __ ] remember yes
yeah well I think yes some people don't
realize to the I make the video all in
one day they're that surprises a lot of
people when they find that oh man it
upload all in one day conceptualize
edit upload oh one day yeah so that's
good I don't always remember what
exactly I made okay well some of these
are gonna be really hard some of these
are gonna be relatively easy mmm thank
you for leaving out anything very old
yeah I just figured it didn't really
apply but anyway let's get started okay
no more dilly-dally what are we calling
this Jenna video trivia I guess Jenna
video trivia long at home
Vivian you might get a better score than
me yeah okay
yeah I'll get we'll give a second for
you guys to answer but only a seconds
hurry up question one am I allowed to
lick spit blow on you scream loudly okay
that is from I'll give them a second ago
that is from you teaching me jujitsu I
think it might be the second one because
I was asking if I could lick spit blow
on you like if these were rules that
applied to jujitsu or not you were right
but it was the first one oh it was your
first it was the it was like anyone's
first class at a martial art when they
asked these normal questions I think
it'd blow on people it's normal things
that you ask in martial listen okay
there's a big weight discrepancy well
you and I are jujitsu Inge so I got to
know what I can get away with to turn
the tide in my advantage
technique okay I don't have any of that
yet and nor do I want any cuz jujitsu is
not the sport Jitsu is the sport for
everyone they just don't know yet okay
ready
I'm gonna start off kind of easy then
we're gonna work our way up okay this is
more this is marble sling this is a five
pound dumbbell
do you know what that is
yes what is it how many balloons will it
take to get my dog for life yep
nice he was so cute during that video he
was he really did like have a good time
he's just sitting in his little bed he's
just a good Bobby boy he's just such a
good Bobby
right it could be in the air right now
he would have no he has no idea where he
is at all times I love him so much
bleach on your face challenge yes I said
that okay so this is either it's either
something like a parody like I was
joking mm-hmm or it's the time that I
bleached my eyebrows and my sideburns
final guess yeah I'm gonna guess that
although my second guess is the Kylie
Jenner lip challenge it sounds like
somebody would have said in that video
it was bleaching your eyebrows
ding-ding-ding you got it right Congrats
yeah okay good job thank you
you want a race sure if you want to lose
your dick do you know what this is I
actually don't stop cheating I'm not
trying not to
can you say it again you want a race
sure if you want to lose your dick was
like I suck at video games videos no
this is one of the oldest ones on this
list I don't know the answer to minute
cardio oh my god
that video got instantly age-restricted
instantly to monetize yeah everything
because like they were all just Google
stock images of like boobs and butts
yeah and well I think Romo had told me
to one of the pictures of the fitness
model that I used for that video the
actual model yeah shout and was like
you're not allowed to use that picture
and it was like I'm really sorry it was
maybe like a quarter of a second and the
internet still doesn't have very good
rules about this when it came out not
like I was making any money off of it
anyways yeah but
I know your insurance doesn't cover
dental but mine sure does that is
something that Hillary Clinton's nice
okay so it's just like look at this
selfie miss this year okay so you're
writing your radio show the other day
and I was at the same table as you just
laughing with my headphones in and I
could tell you were annoyed at me but
that's always oh yeah I was watching
Hillary shaking the table and laughing
as I'm like on a deadline to finish my
show sake yeah those were some of my
favorite videos you've done - I have a
lot of favorite videos that you've done
but that one was really good I just the
whole series was so good man I'm with
you on that and that I don't even
they're not even good like it's not a
good impression it just doesn't really
make any sense but it just like really
makes me laugh I was probably the
hardest that we had been it was the
hardest for us to not break and laugh
during filming because it's just so we
were just dying all the time are you
ready for when I was sitting on the
beanbag chair and you were moving
because I was working out for you it's
nothing to do with anything doesn't make
any sense
it was brilliant I loved it okay he
looked like he looked like the kind of
orthodontist that didn't go to school
okay that is from with bad apps
guess which one doesn't matter you got
it right but guess which one it's
probably three or four five five it's
when I was giving yeah I know you're
giving me a recent set of braces see how
they're all just leaning into the middle
of my face
I can't straighten them out they don't
care about me the only thing I can think
of that would be leaning into the middle
of my face is when I gave myself eyelash
extension correct ding ding ding nice
good job
Kermit we're in this for the long haul
but it's not going to take five minutes
we know we already know it's a lie that
is when I made that awful Gene's chair
correct
five minutes keep that away yeah greed
is greed and all dogs have it has to
have been a dog video yes I don't know
there's so many choices of videos when
they're being greedy
I was filmed out in the world buying my
dogs everything yes correct
Carmy so greedy but I love you I love
how that video he was just picking out
everything for himself and then peeing
all over the [ __ ] driver I can't
believe I still can't believe he did
that okay this is a conversation Jenna
are you pregnant Shane Dawson yeah wait
what there's no way you're gonna get
this well I don't understand oh it's you
probably don't remember saying it the
whole thing was very disorienting I
think so Jenna said are you pregnant and
then Shane Dawson replies yeah is that
when we did this speech jammer no but
close is this a podcast no it's from
your video I only did one video with
Shane on my channel it's this face swap
or what no that's it it was when you
called people but couldn't hear them oh
god I just realized that he was that
your mom and Shane they were such good
sports no they were like so into it and
like a dying laughing and it was just so
cute I you literally were like are you
pregnant he's like yeah
man has good
she's just something else so we're
cooking some la tap water was this one
obviously we were cooking mm-hmm was
this when we were cooking Thanksgiving
food nope a birthday cake nope
I don't know
boyfriend cooks my favorite meal Leisure
Suit video oh these are tough yeah this
is a wine that I said in one of your
videos I'm allowed to do that right I
don't know what's your favorite part of
scissors mine's the handle cuz it's safe
I don't know it sounds like we're doing
some type of craft and or nails or
something that required scissors
was it a Christmas doing drunk Christmas
crafts no ratham there you go yeah
that's a that was the wrong yeah I don't
know if you know this but I'm American
bruja Todd and I help me okay what I
said that yep again might be willing
that you don't remember saying excuse I
said that you recited the Chanukah
prayer and then said help me tell me
about it I I concurred that I have no
idea well you you had guessed this video
earlier in the game I have no idea that
doesn't help
drunk Pinterest Christmas oh nice Wow
home stuff I feel like that's not a
sentence that should ever be a thing
No mm-hmm no pigeon but it is and I
wrote it out okay ready you might get
this one get that off your [ __ ] head
you damn idiot here's a hint you were
talking to me is it when I glued
eyelashes to a wig out in the world is
it the thrift store video they did
softball I was wearing a visor and you
said keep it off your [ __ ] head you
damn idiot Wow you're pretending to be
my coach
it wasn't let me guess
I did you guessing to get two videos
damn do you want me to give you more
time to guess hmm just another hint
okay there is a shockingly low amount of
women giving themselves beards on
purpose made of hair on YouTube it's
when I give myself a beer there you go
nice back in the back in the winning
column I'll take one [ __ ] me up fam and
a knife see that is so difficult because
that's hard it's hard I'm waiting you
can take your time Julianne I didn't
even finish my sentence I'm sorry that's
so difficult because there's so many
videos when we said [ __ ] me out Finn
Rutger I have to think of the time that
we may have used a knife let me give you
some hit K I give you some hints a pair
I haven't even guessed yet okay is it a
paraffin wax adventure correct sorry I'm
just trying to help here good job you
doing good
well
okay I know he likes to rub his face on
these but I don't know if he prefers to
rub his face on these that's definitely
about Kermit and that's definitely about
my dog reviews soap well done
nailed it because that I was putting out
the wipes for him to wipe his face on
that was a really funny video
do you remember filming that just being
like I don't know what we're doing I
know what are we doing I know I know
and then when he started actually
rubbing his face in the Irish Spring we
were like oh my god it's happening yeah
but like the idea of uploading a video
where your dog reviews soap is just so
ridiculous so [ __ ] out there I love
you it feels like you're standing on
some softish Legos I have no idea try to
imagine what that sensation feels like
soft dish Legos what have you stood on
that felt like I felt like that mmm I
don't know I'm not usually standing on
something in a video so you were being
crafty with my feet that's all I'm gonna
say I don't love seconds I don't know
I'm stumped that was when you did hot
glue crafts and you made the hot glue
say oh those terrible sandals oh I'm
still mad okay you were really angry at
those really mad it does more nasty in
the morning bright nasty I think that is
from when I filmed my dog whenever he
cried or was nasty for 24 hour correct
good job it's real easy all you need is
your hands step one find your hands
so I know that I started saying that
after I made landshark hmm but then I
don't know when I said that again cuz I
would that's something I would just say
yeah I have no idea
can I give you a hint sure but the top
comment on the video says this wasn't a
video this was an experience that's all
for the healthy okay permit threw up in
this video it's a body massage okay
imagine me on the basketball court and
my basketball game tomorrow
flowing curly red locks that's when I
gave myself up her nice nice yeah
there's no way you're gonna get this but
I had to put it on it's very hard okay
if it was up to me I'd build you a
prison out of wallpaper context yeah I
have no idea it was a fam fan submitted
type of episode of your video where you
got took things that people submitted
was reading mean comments for my dogs
mm-hmm I rant for you i rant for you it
was so random it was like I don't even
know you're talking about but it was
such a funny quote if someone that plays
a pant a piano is a pianist
then why isn't someone who plays the
banjo a B genus yeah it's not even a
good thought to have anywhere
B genus okay I'm surprised Marbles knows
which end to eat his food with that was
that I'm reading me comments which end
like he's a worm like he just has like
two ends hello hello you're a day late
trash truck you should have is
yesterday's trash day I thought
the buck step the [ __ ] up trash okay
life is short but also like terribly and
insufferably long at the same time me a
tooth best that's one of your mommy
misquotes want to be a tooth brush for
Halloween ding dong hai my dog's want to
come to your house is that ok ok this is
definitely when we I let my dogs walk me
because we're talking about how they
like to go trick-or-treating yep like
every little opening they start just
beautiful so this is another one of my
quotes so you go right over the middle
then left over the middle and right over
the middle then left then right over the
middle hold on and then you end strong
with oh right over the middle purpose
following hair braiding tutorial nice
fun okay this is a good quote you ready
for this one yep
the stand this is you talking to me the
standing with your leg all the way up on
the counter is like a lot for right now
oh you're cooking my sub ending our old
house was it in this house it was in
this house you put your foot on this
counter boy I put on our counter oh oh
okay so you were ringing the Rompin no
was it when you were the juicy cowboy no
oh you're getting warmer though I don't
know brats oh yeah as a bad style
wearing a skirt that was a lot for you a
lot for right now I'm gonna do it again
I'm okay for right now just like cover
your face and neck and [ __ ] with some
Vaseline yeah [ __ ] my neck no I have no
idea well
I'll let you let me know you want to
is it a relaxing time with just for men
no don't know I'm not looking but you
just keep like flashing your paper at me
I have no idea
Oh was it uh when I dyed my own hair yes
beautiful
see you in Vaseline is for you no that's
for dyeing your hair mm-hmm and for
covering your body head to toe hmm so
hot poke me with your thoughts it
distorts my vision when I smile I'd
never said that and not say that what is
that sentence okay let's try to separate
these okay so hot poke me with your
thoughts that's one thing you can block
that out of your memory and then focus
on the second part it distorts my vision
when I smile why would your vision be
distorted when you're smiling was it
when I covered my face and minds yes
nice you got it babe it was like a weird
sentence that's what this game is hmm
should I really just go full-blown I'm
lost at the supermarket can you help me
is that how I used to do my makeup in
high school no was it uh giving myself a
hair up no but way warmer um I was doing
oh give me a [ __ ] up family hmm I
don't know tape in extensions oh yeah
all right the last couple are kind of
hard but I'll help you out I didn't say
it was gonna be a human face was this
when I transformed myself into Kermit or
transformed myself into a chair no and
he hit it has to do
your face transforming mm-hmm and the
title of video is pretty straightforward
prosthetics yeah what does it tell that
video I want a new face yes there it is
nice all right last one I just look like
a filthy old man that was a reverse
contour yeah yeah look like my father
okay I think that's all of them
let's see how you did and you did 23 out
of 33 let's see if you passed I did it I
don't think Oh No
almost 69 that's a D+ I take it deep
blows hold on see me after class oh no I
gotta see me after class
oh no in a sad face slanty mouth face oh
no not quite sad also you're gonna need
your parents to sign that please no was
that fun for you yeah I mean you picked
very obscure think that's kinda what
makes it fun I know cuz if you picked
stuff that was super straightforward
then it would be way too easy and I
think it would be way too easy for
people listening to as well but there's
like these are good sentences though
because there's like enough of a hint
and a lot of them you know yeah that was
yeah for sure really good job Julian
well you know it always a pleasure to go
back and watch some of the art that
you've created over the years yes the
art artists hate you I'm saying on
ironically even though it came out
ironically artists for my newest
installation I'm gonna wear a green
shirt on my chest is this performance
art Beach well hopefully if you guys
played at home you enjoyed it and
hopefully you did better than a 69 first
I just can't believe like
the way that you read these and said
them out of context I'm like I never
said that
that's not something that I said well to
be fair like there were a handful of
them like the drunk one or the one where
you're not listening to the phone call
like there's no way you could remember
saying that because it was such a weird
experience I don't know if you know this
but I'm American peruca Todd and I
helped me that's what you said when
you're doing drunk Pinterest crafts for
Christmas you want to raise sure if you
want to lose your dick
I just said dick like a thousand two
doesn't step on it go back and pick up
you stupid we laughed a lot making that
one no I'm actually gonna need your
parents signature on that please no I
don't wanna hopefully I didn't go to her
on you but maybe we'll do this again oh
no fun though yeah well there you go you
spam the same suggestion in a bunch of
conversations is it for you that's well
thank you guys for listening to our
podcast we'll be back next week with
another episode and that's really good
child it's for me because it's mine and
then um we actually I'm not sure if we
normally every year we take Labor Day
and birthdays off as well as like
Christmas another major holidays but
Labor Day and your birthday are pretty
close to each other yeah so we might
take my birthday off yet we might take
it off we don't know okay we yeah we're
not sure I don't know yeah we'll keep
you guys posted it depends on how the
birthday girl is feeling and what we
want to do but um I'm gonna do nothing
yeah anyway we'll be back next week
hope you guys enjoyed and we'll be live
on Twitch all week so hang out with us
there and we'll see on the next podcast
thanks for hanging bye y'all
[Music]